ce taux
non
je sois gelé
mon vieux
1978 la france découvre la voix de
fabienne thibeault à 26 ans elle et
marie jeanne dans starmania
près de quarante ans plus tard l'opéra
rock ne l'a pas quitté starmania
complètement fondatrice de ma vie c'est
à partir de starmania cloud public m'a
reconnu ma rencontre et m'a suivi
starmania et un vraiment un patrimoine
de notre culture populaire musicale
beaucoup de tubes beaucoup de thèmes
aussi que si on trait extrêmement et
fondateur de ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui
dans le bon comme dans le moins bon
le 7 juin elle sera accompagnée de cinq
chanteurs ils mêleront titres
incontournables de la comédie musicale
les morceaux québécois une soirée
organisée avec le lion's club de
rambouillet la vie de la cité a montré
qu'il y avait ce problème de pour les
personnes isolées pour les personnes
dépendantes de trouver un délit q la
disposition pour pouvoir circuler pour
aller faire ses courses pour aller chez
le médecin il allait demander à la
voisine et quand on a un problème de
personnes isolées
c'est difficile le club espère récolter
8500 euros lors de cette soirée pour que
ce titre de luc plamondon et michel
berger ne soit plus d'actualité
toujours
[Musique]